hey guys Greg Nickels here with string
theory comm and today we're talking
about squatting specifically why you can
squat more low bar than high bar so the
first thing we need to talk about
obviously is how bar position changes
the mechanics of the lift
and quite frankly at least for light
loads it doesn't change it all that much
basically all you're doing is dropping
the bar two to three inches further down
your back onto your rear deltoids
instead of all your traps and frankly
this just doesn't make that big of a
difference where the bar is is always
going to be situated right around over
mid foot and so you see here that when
you're dealing with similar degrees of
knee flexion and hip flexion if you're
changing our position two to three
inches here the torso segments are ten
percent different in length
so the average torso is 30 inches long
just using average population data so a
10 percent shift is realistic and if you
assume same degrees of dorsiflexion knee
flexion then the only thing that changes
is hip flexion and it's actually quite a
small change only two to three degrees
obviously this doesn't tend to square
with what we see in the gym and in the
real world so the next question becomes
why do low bar squats tend to look more
hip dominant than high bar squats why
why don't they look alike
why your knees tend to go slightly
farther forward for high bar squats and
your hips tend to go slightly farther
back for load bar squat the primary
reason for the difference you observe
primarily has to do with the fact that
the bottom of the squat is the most
challenging part of the movement for the
quads so essentially with a max load the
knee extension torque that you have to
produce is going to be at its maximal
until
has two components there's moment arm
length and there's resistance so let's
assume you can squat about ten percent
more low bar than high bar so that's ten
percent more resistance so you need
about a 10 percent shorter moment arm so
the way that manifests itself is the
knees shift backwards slightly making up
that 10 percent difference but that also
causes the hips to shift back slightly
which is what you tend to see with low
bar squats so this raises an interesting
quandary around parallel and through the
sticking point for low bar and high bar
squats you're dealing with similar knee
extension torque which that arises
because it's the most you can possibly
handle however since those hips shift
backwards slightly with low bar squats
you're dealing with quite a bit more
required hip extension torque because
one the moment arm is longer because the
knees and hips both shift back a little
bit and the loads heavier so both of
those variables that go into the torque
calculation both of those are increased
for low bar squatting so same knee
extension torque so that should be just
as hard more hip extension torque so
that should be even harder however you
can lift more weight so the question
becomes what is the limiting factor so
really you only have two potential
options the first is that it's your
calves the ability to produce plantar
flexion which I hope we can all agree
right off the bat that your calves
aren't the limiting factor in your squat
so the only other option you have is
your back strength your spinal erectors
your ability to keep your spine extended
to transfer that force from your legs
and your hips into the bar now this may
not sit well with some people because a
lot of people have the idea that low bar
squats are harder for your back because
they see that you're leaning over
farther and typically when you're
leaning over
that means that something is going to be
harder for your back however that's only
true when you're comparing like
exercises so if you're comparing say a
low bar squat with a certain degree of
forward lean and a low bar squat with a
greater degree of forward lean then yes
the low bar squat with the greater
degree of forward lean is going to
present a greater challenge to your back
however when you're comparing different
exercises then you have movement arms of
different links that you're dealing with
and it's not only the degree of forward
lean it's also the degree that simply
the shift in barbell position changes
those moment arms and the amount of
torque that those spinal erectors have
to produce to keep the spine extended so
to explain this a bit by way of analogy
the front squat most people would agree
that the front squat tends to present a
greater challenge to your back extensors
your spinal erectors then the low bar
squat does if you don't then it's
probably just because you have in front
squatted very much a lot of times your
legs and hips are capable of lifting a
much heavier load than your back is so
now to see how this principle applies
directly to high bar and low bar
squatting the black curvy line running
through the picture represents the spine
with a natural lumbar and thoracic
curvature the two red circles at the top
right represent high bar and low bar
position the one on the right is high
bar one on the left is low bar and the
arrows represent the spinal extension
moment arms for the thoracic extensors
and the lumbar extensors the orange ones
for high bar and the green ones for low
bar so as you can see because the low
bar position has the bar sitting
slightly higher and when in hip flexion
farther forward
for both the thoracic and lumbar spines
the absolute difference in momen r is
greater for high bar than low bar you'll
also notice that the relative difference
is greater for the thoracic spine than
it is for the lumbar spine so if we
assume a 10% difference in bar load
there might be a about a 10% difference
in momen arm when we're comparing the
lumbar spine
however it's probably closer to a 25 to
30 percent difference when we're
comparing the thoracic spine which is
similar in principle to from squatting
even though the load is slightly less
because the relative length of that
moment arm is quite a bit longer that
still means even with a lower weight
you're presenting a larger relative
challenge to those thoracic erectors to
keep the spine extended so you can
transfer that force from your legs and
hips into the bar so that's the primary
reason once you look at everything it's
not your quads it's certainly not your
hip extensors because they're having to
work harder for low bar and I think we
can safely assume it's not your calves
so it has to be well and it's not those
it's probably not those lumbar extensors
either because when you look at the
total torque they have to produce even
though the moment arm is longer for high
bar
that's probably canceled out by the
slightly less amount of weight so torque
is probably similar however there's a
pretty sizable difference in the
thoracic spine so there's probably where
our weakness is coming from so back
strength is the main factor specifically
thoracic erector strength however
there's something else that plays into
this as well I'll be it to a slightly
lesser degree and that is where the
bottom position is so with low bar squat
since you're in a few greater degrees of
hip flexion with any
saluté amount of dorsiflexion in
deflection what that's going to mean is
you simply hit the bottom position of a
squat you reach that full hip flexion
position a little bit sooner and that
means essentially that when you're
getting that rebound that stretch reflex
that it is going to help carry you
through a more relevant portion of the
lift what you see here is based on
research the average sticking point of
the squat slightly above parallel femur
at about a 30 degree angle to the floor
so when you're doing slightly deeper
high bar squats you catch that stretch
reflex you're quite a bit below parallel
it helps you get that bounce but then
it's largely dissipated by the time
you're even nearing that sticking point
the biggest portion of the lift
however for low bar squats since you're
in a few greater degrees of hip flexion
you hit that bottom position a little
bit higher that stretch reflex helps
carry you through a somewhat more
relevant portion of the lift so you may
still have some speed and power from
that stretch reflex still hanging around
as you start approaching that sticking
point meaning that you may have a little
bit more speed going into the sticking
point to help you carry through it
instead of having to get through it
mainly on just pure horsepower the same
way you would have to for a high bar
squat that is the major reason why a lot
of weight lifters who have turned a
power lifter do tend to squat a little
bit more low bar that high bar however
the spread isn't nearly as large as it
is for power lifters for power lifters
about a 10 percent spread is pretty
common
however for weight lifters that's quite
a bit smaller and the main reason for
that is remember the primary limiting
factor is thoracic erector strength
weightlifting training you're doing a
ton of pulls you're doing a ton of front
squats a lot of things that really put a
premium on upper back strength so
they're less likely to be limited by
that the
a powerlifter is however where that
bottom position is having a slightly
higher natural bottom position because
most people once they've been under the
bar for a while
realize that if you can sink the squat a
couple inches deeper and catch that
stretch reflex you tend to be stronger
than cutting it a couple inches higher
not necessarily a couple inches above
parallel but you know let's say you can
you can squat three inches below
parallel and that's your bottom position
where you catch that stretch reflex
you'll tend to be a little bit stronger
squatting all the way down there than
you would if you could it's a one-inch
below parallel so that's still in play
so a lot of weight lifters when they
make the switch over to powerlifting max
Aida and chin way lean are two great
examples of this they've moved over to
low bar squatting for powerlifting
because it is still somewhat
advantageous
however the spread between their high
bar and low bar squats isn't nearly as
great as it would be for someone who's
only been a power lifter because since
they have that weightlifting background
they're not as limited by that thoracic
extensor strength so in wrapping up
those are the two main reasons why you
can squat more low bar than high bar in
spite of the fact that low bar has the
same knee extension demands in even
greater hip extension demands the first
thing is you're less likely to be
limited by spinal erectors strength
specifically thoracic erectors and the
second thing is that stretch reflex
tends to help you out through a more
relevant portion of the lift closer to
parallel and through the sticking point
now just in conclusion one of the pieces
of pushback that I'm expecting to give
is someone to post a picture similar to
this one of someone doing a low bar
squat with a super upright bottom
position and say oh no one who low bar
squats looks like that no one's that
bright you're trying to say that these
are two quite similar movements with
just a couple small differences between
them but see look at this picture of
someone with beautiful bottom position
of a high bar squat
lobar squad will never look like that
this is complete nonsense however
remember the most relevant portion of
the lift when we're talking about
mechanics and what's likely to be the
limiting factor is where you miss the
lift which tends to be somewhere around
parallel to just above parallel through
that sticking point and when you compare
even someone who has a really a bright
super deep bottom position for a high
bar squat like this when they start
coming up out of the hole their hips
tend to kick back and they wind up in a
position that looks much much more
similar to the one we're talking about
and if you'll notice there's quite a bit
of forward lean still it looks well like
a low bar squat except the bar a couple
inches up higher and conversely a low
bar squat through the sticking point
unless it's someone who has just a super
super hip dominant squat tends to look
like a high bar squat with the bar two
or three inches lower and that's what
you would expect because bar position
doesn't really change that much even
though people like to make a big deal
about it alright guys so that's all I've
got for this video I'm sure you are
starting to get tired of hearing me
rambling but if this is a subject that
interests you check out the description
there will be four or five articles down
there that I've written about this topic
that go into quite a bit more depth if
you'd like to deepen your understanding
of this specific topic but also just
squatting mechanics in general as always
if you liked the video please like and
subscribe and thanks a lot for watching